I'm headed to the American Philosophical
Society in Philadelphia to meet with its
librarian Patrick Spiro he studies
documents dating back to the time of the
country's founding what you're looking
at here is one of the first printings of
the Declaration of Independence the
first section is the preamble yeah and
this is where they talk about life
liberty and the pursuit of happiness and
the idea is that individuals should be
free to do these things and government
is constituted to protect those graters
and what the King has done is broken
that contract broken that trust and so
they have to be freed from the king in
order to be free to do what they want
now can you say that this was the first
time a group of people decided that they
wanted to be free to do whatever the
heck they wanted to do well I think it's
the first time that it was ever written
in a official way but this is not the
only version of the Declaration of
Independence that survives the other
document that I want to show you is this
Thomas Jefferson's draft of the
Declaration of Independence and you can
see on the side there's these notes yeah
once Congress got their hands on this
they started changing words changing
meetings I think the most notable one is
in that famous phrase that people are
endowed with certain unalienable rights
Jefferson originally wrote inherent and
inalienable rights inherent rights which
Jefferson used several times means that
all people are born with it with these
rights okay so if these rights are not
inherent then
you're not necessarily born with them
only a few people are born with them and
they're applied only to white society
like male yes yes
[Music]
you